um guys we are here to podcast with
chris d'elia and i want to start this in
all seriousness with saying something
nice about each other I'm cutting
there's a lot of negativity in the world
and I just feel like [ __ ] you that
really didn't last long man that's not
good well I do like the vibe Brian I'm
sorry
we're gonna start saying please put on
shades Oh Chris you know why that makes
me upset I know you know what like doing
it positive and we are and I don't like
putting my shades on yeah but my future
is too bright all right man well mine
you're making it hard to say something
nice please please please don't please
be charitable with us as well when we're
degree okay there's a reason why Shawn
and I have sunglasses I mean you don't
have yours on you know you do you put
some guys on the back your head you're
that guy okay look it's past guys listen
up listen up I'm trying to be really
popular okay okay and and I and so I'll
start by rising above your insults
because you're barred and six now I'm
not sold and it's okay well I didn't
tell you though because you guys are
young so it's fine
first of all you're young so that's a
lot of guys are you guys are doing well
and you're up-and-coming now you're not
I would say Chris you're almost gonna be
you're gonna be 40 soon and well so it
had actually what I have seen happen in
a movie way for you really or a new
movies coming out this year you know
what I mean no one coming out a week
thank you it's not that big what has
happened yeah and things didn't you know
they didn't he wasn't able to carry the
show through right and that's okay
because very few people can do that
here's what's good about you is that you
work social media really well audience
you have a young audience I feel like
you're being mean kind no no I'm being
look at this just in this just in dude
yeah this just in on deadlines Chris
D'Elia to star in psychopath comedy
series and works at YouTube red what's
that and it's going on there no that's
great and it's what's going on there
today it came out what the [ __ ] eight
years ago would you everyone I see this
picture ah I say you lead singer
Nickelback yeah I buy it basically you
played a nickel well let me sing why'd
you why'd you hold on
why did you take a photo shoot like this
though I didn't mean to
first of all congrats it's thank you
cool psychopath comedy series yeah is
that muscle brand is that you can you
bring this up it's on okay can we stand
point
you look like Russell Brand and I think
that I don't really look you have his um
you have his energy can I tell you some
that's a that your hair style here huh
no no that's that's just how it was
Chris why you serious look at that man
that I told him because you know how
this one you don't know how this works
are you Lee friends you never mentioned
but they just grab a shot from online
dude they don't ask you for a pic dude
just [ __ ] about this for positive you
know what and speaking of congrats thank
you very much all right I have a podcast
congratulations now I want to let you
guys know my [ __ ] I'm not trying to pull
my [ __ ] now my [ __ ] is rising it is
rising and this podcast is good and you
know what I stopped making a podcast
because it's not in the podcast business
yeah you're I have a cult and it's a
cult and I am and I can't and we are
that you look you look like the guy who
killed everyone in wake up Chris you
can't just admit I would never kill
anybody but my goal is to get this
podcast going so much so that I have
followers and then we go to a log cabin
and we chill out and we sit down for the
rest of your life and we learn and we
talk about commodity and wanna share
ideas and I appoint people elders and I
don't know if you've been looking online
I'm gonna hang this up yeah I want to
bring this up but tell you what talk
about a nice thing you guys are two
elders on I call
Brenden shop oh you got the official pin
I'm not wearing your true Bacon's
charisma resist his charisma into one be
lucky we knew it stick together
should I quit this no well I mean you
keep it going for a little bit but once
we get to the Lark Airmen it's gonna be
great this all makes so much sense
put the pin on Brandon don't put up a
good look at me Ryan that's what they do
they make you feel important you are
important Ryan you are important I'm not
it you're very important doesn't make
you and you're important to me in your
important to all of us thank you if
you're a member of my call and also you
know the podcast and you guys are
subscribing yeah you're another you guys
support what what we support the cause
because I know I know he's hypnotic as
[ __ ] so charming huh Brandon look at me
this stays with me people say it's okay
with me yeah yeah but the certificate
down wait what I'll say I signed it for
you to get a pal they shouldn't let it
be down the pendant shavon Bryan Callen
I I don't say accessible oh and you are
hold on is about the certificate
eldership says let it be known that
Bryan Callen and Brendan Schaub have
demonstrated an exceptional commitment
to living and spreading baby ship in the
world and honoring the congratulations
show with the kazoo with the consent of
daddy parentheses crystally a pet this
person henceforth carries the status of
elder we simply have to free and he
signed it dude
this is legit you are you are a very
dangerous person nice right it's a good
no thank you but thanking you are we the
first elders crazy like 12
what else is elder some really really
people
some people who really really really
people who really spread the word and
help but like who though work they've so
what do we spread the word Chris what is
your cult stand for what do we what do
we say about your cretinism okay let me
explain what that is hedonism is the
pursuit of pleasure okay so in other
words it's the pursue the apathetic
pleasures like sex or min and Brandon
that's not a good example I live my life
like that yeah but he's not your daddy
no but in the montage Caleb no dude you
have a lot of it and we're gonna wear
white linen it's gonna be crazy I love
white charisma really into fashion and
do we're cool shoes oh yeah yes yes and
we talk about use material there's girls
oh there's girls they're in they're
beautiful and they aim to please and
honestly there's like there also if you
got if you like guys to that's that's in
no listen it will be Brandon Brendon his
neck is getting all weak Brandon tighten
your mouth tighten your mouth come back
over here I know what the pin actually
looks really good on you look Han Rendon
he's [ __ ] charming as [ __ ] he's got
tremendous charisma
that's what cult leaders do are though
Jordan threesome and yes sir man listen
Chris it's work you know look at his
[ __ ] eyes don't look at the picture
don't look in his eyes for real can I
have your girl no you can have them all
no that's what they do you have all my
shoes and clothes fact he's trying to
take everything for you and alright it's
an RS 7 but yeah don't get all ass yeah
yeah present see my good grades a
dolphin oh nothing alright listen bro
I'm so hard right now I'm not gonna look
in your eyes but I'm so bored that guy
you're welcome
Oh frame those and put those up and you
know what all framing that's funny yeah
yeah yeah well add it to the dick diver
picture nice okay Chris cosa um I know
that you're 90
you're about 85% serious about your call
so yeah and so I don't approve yo you
know what dude you know what you are
jealous dude what a cold no I'm not
I want to go I'm now you can have one if
you join mine no we all have it I'm not
joining your coke dude dude how awesome
would it be to just be in [ __ ] tall
grass chilling out and there's like and
we're just playing but we're set there's
no music and maybe like the closest
thing to us is like a general store and
we just kind of like lounge around
people massage our legs and we talk and
share ideas dude yes about what do you
don't have a boy I do dude like what
okay well meet a couple of ideas because
you guys always want to you guys always
want to kind of restructure Society it's
an idea don't trust cult leaders I'm
sorry and I don't trust cults no hats oh
no hats no hats that's it how is that an
idea how is it not an idea what rubber a
ball cap that's it if you need something
to [ __ ] okay I love ball caps there
you go but if you're gonna wear a
[ __ ] fedora or a bowlers casting
stand for besides pleasure you got a lot
to learn dude
that's why did that seems to volume you
know what can I answer straight if you
have to ask that's true don't know you
don't see me ask all these stupid
questions yeah dude you know what's
going on here Chris you jealous Brian he
wants a grand in blind blind allegiance
to a leader like Chris will get you
killed
I'm not blind Brent what's a call and
we're not Seavey they say you know what
I've seen how this story goes down I
followed the whole Manson family story
note see that's what he's trying to do
would you would you have what do you
stand for do you do you accept all
members of society or are you gonna try
to turn your people against certain
people I know what you're saying you're
saying it's like a little bit like
Stalin or it's a little bit like sure
that's how it happens I do [ __ ] starts
you require a blind allegiance to you
and your cause yes but I'm never gonna
steer you wrong there it is but I'm not
gonna steer everyone down you're not
gonna steer everybody wrong so you're
the one who's actually at the wheel
thank you we you're saying I didn't I'm
saying don't say thank you because I
didn't give you that you're not driving
my bus
oh all right you're not driving my bus
so but you want to drive the bus right
and you want everybody else to follow
you right you want everybody in the
passenger seat right if they want to
which is a good idea yeah but you can I
add this bride and I think this might
help you jump on board the baby train
yeah
now do you offer any sort of benefits
like would you fix Bryan's teeth would
you cut is like do you guys offer any
fashion advice oh yeah we might now we
do we sit and we yeah we would do that
we would play we could pay for that too
what else do you need right now this is
what I need Chris and I want you to
answer this question yo and this is
gonna this is gonna pop you out of it
hey Chris well when a follower breaks
your rule yeah what do you do to them
they've got a legit question they're
banned they're good they live very far
away yeah so so that's it so they wait
cause one indiscretion you kick them out
yeah but dude they don't have to cause
an indiscretion okay but what would be
an indiscretion yeah like what are the
rules here like showing up with a
[ __ ] hat they know better oh my god
you see what happened so now you have a
dress code that makes sense I mean it's
not a dress code as more as this is
suggestion and what do they have to call
you daddy or mommy oh my [ __ ] god me
might be an issue but daddy I'm on board
about what if they say call you Chris
well I didn't I didn't picked that name
did I that was just given to me
there's you are you are such a dangerous
person that I want to be popular
acceptable is that cool yeah if you're
like Spanish or some [ __ ] okay I want
everybody to know that this is up so
clearly a negative thing to be associate
it's not any because you got to mind
control that's exactly why we need this
cult because you you are admitting that
you have a car yeah you know what I am I
am admitting that I have a cult [ __ ] all
this negativity about cults this shit's
awesome dude and we I mean what else you
know yeah it's a supportive group do we
help our own can I ask you another
question
do you set up a money to be in your cult
it's not a half do thing it's a so there
is money involved well you need money to
live
I'll call donations it is called
donations and we'd love to [ __ ]
abolish all of money and just go off
trade great but what would your what
would your how much money do you do you
request as a donation Chris you know
dude just answer the question no I don't
want to answer the question is because
you you have an answer but your your
your barrel I'm a no money off this
called so far
well how much that's okay how much are
you asking your followers for what is
the initiation fee hey man what didn't
you see what happens yeah because he's
secretive and what is five percent forty
five percent of what their income the
total that you know it seems fair you
hear this not even after taxes
oh well arrest you're doing it so lazy
where does the money go the hedonistic
life on so you just spend it on yourself
or us us but you know mainly you though
on the leader
you're so lazy so lazy we all right hey
was tell us about the psychopathy county
see what's up with this man I just got
too much [ __ ] going on a good doctor
he's on the good doctor he's on alone
together he's got a movie coming out
called half magic he's got a movie
coming out called life in year and you
know what do it me talk and also and
also I got this new tour that I'm
starting called follow the leader and it
looks like a cool picture from well I
mean whatever you call her you want to
say people say propaganda but it's like
what we're doing is reaching a cause and
what we're doing is cause we have a
place that we can all come together and
[ __ ] celebrate man okay let me ask up
Tommy Cole picture up that was tourism
this is a very important question to our
our young guys allowed in your cult yeah
but a lot of guys a lot of young you
know I'll get the race how many young
guys are actually in your call what is
the girl-to-guy ratio crazy pens look at
that wave it or unbelievable it is
wooden why is that baby explain that the
three be constrain this [ __ ] picture
all right dude hey and also I see Denver
on there I'm here on my banana I'm proud
hey hold on let me
you need my privacy I don't I don't know
I honestly don't where you at in Denver
some [ __ ] theater yeah my last eight
no I'm not quite yeah Pepsi nice I don't
know any other purse you gonna know
about this I don't know any I don't know
actually he's actually he you are so
blatantly a cult leader cause babies
went back down until we have a log cabin
in the woods we're all wearing white
cloth talking about things in very calm
voices no chairs we stay on the ground
we feel the earth what up what a
[ __ ] thing but sometimes I got I get
to sit in chairs still and also there
will be chairs at my shows because they
will be in theaters but whatever cities
cities and more cities at Chris Leo calm
the cities here are just the first few
I'm adding many cities later say cities
more Chris so sound off in the comments
below so my question is are you with us
or are you piece of [ __ ] so you're at
maybe soon hashtag for Holden you are
you are horrible
you're admitting anybody who's not with
you is a piece of [ __ ] oh my gosh and
just liked it you guys resist everybody
resist Chris right yeah let's [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] with [ __ ] that you want to
[ __ ] your [ __ ] there let me be the
top bro Oh probably I'll beat up you
know what I'll be the bottom oh god you
know what dude follow the leader tour
tickets on sale for the general public
Friday hey you with us are you a piece
of [ __ ] alright that doesn't look so
much like that's a good campaign you got
roll in there thanks you know what dude
because here's the thing oh dude
either you do comedy okay cool you have
a podcast let's all streamline it it's a
call
and it's got such a negative thing you
know what Oh culture I was like we're
not a call we're not a cult I am a call
girl I am a cult now [ __ ] it dude like
that he's hitting it head-on they'll be
you know a lot of people don't they
don't let's do it - let's do it
no I'm like sucking and [ __ ] no no
Brennan as a student in history this guy
is a dangerous he's a dangerous person
well I like what he's put in I'm like
sucking and [ __ ] you don't like
sucking and [ __ ] I mean so just some no
go sometimes it's [ __ ] guy
I'll get the [ __ ] out of here Tommy and
this sucking [ __ ] Eton chilling
petting massaging art legs dude get the
[ __ ] out of here man you don't like that
[ __ ]
you don't like nice like feeling like
that like a woman just kind of your
heads in her lap and she's doing it like
that sort of no not sort of and you like
it you love it I love it get the [ __ ] to
the log cabin Wow so dangerous mom and
anyone I'm more dangerous in this
country dude I'm living a hedonistic
lifestyle man are you what the [ __ ] I
want
I got brown rice and eggs whatever the
[ __ ] I want you see maybe you are some
real fire not date no hay and ice cream
at night do you see how angry he isn't
date I know busby remember he said you
want this to be a positive podcast and I
feel like you're poking the bear here so
he has a call I'm not but I'm look
Booker I'm holding the [ __ ] baby in
that picture you're good my hands aren't
you it's a painting dude you know I mean
it's my life and it's it's a toddler
it's not even a baby I got to tell you
oh yeah that's a Tommy that's like the
[ __ ] you know 9 it's like a year old
maybe I don't know man you you don't
even I'm looking at the kid what's that
kid's name Chris you know what that
kid's name is what you you see - it's
not me no no is that all for your shower
unit for your body awesome you know
that's it's everybody not babies mm-hmm
the first thing they do is they come up
with a general philosophy that everybody
everybody falls to like your Nazis it
uses rats well but you know harsh no
Brendan that's that's an extreme exact
same example that's this is what leads
this is where it leads
crazy mystic lifestyle man Chris
because more pleasure though and fun
yeah but if you're not in you know as
you are you know you aren't what your
the no fun place yeah dude
my positive it I'm out [ __ ] annoying
is in no fun put what do the kids call
him Chris a hater
yeah alright we're gonna we're only
spoiler with an ain't gonna do a
research we're gonna do a reset Chris
say something nice about me okay please
Chris I think would they're shutting you
out of rapper stuck your [ __ ] foot
before yeah oh yeah you guys [ __ ]
sabotage me dude this was on the ground
already we did not stop you what is that
Laffy Taffy right it's a [ __ ] it's a
water bottle leaders don't they call
eaters take themselves very seriously
and they take and they get really mad at
any slight see what's happening with you
guys put hoursa sabotage me and made me
look stupid
didn't chris nobody did that you guys
did do that see see what pattern and
honestly if we were if we were chilling
outside you'd have to go back to the
lock heaven and do some chores like so
you do have punishment well it's not
punishment it's just help you're helping
now you you're a sweeper I'm a sweeper
here you go any old landscaping duty so
say something nice okay about day and
then alright better be genuine alright
and it better be positive Chris I like
Brendan's attitude I think he's got a
great attitude and I think he's a
go-getter and I think he [ __ ] won't
stop and he's a [ __ ] juggernaut
thanks man no problem in any sense of
the word to juggernaut yeah he's a
juggernaut okay great yeah good stuff
talk about me yeah you honestly know be
nice Chris I'm gonna positive I'm gonna
be positive day remember that time we
went to dinner with a bunch of people
and we were at this restaurant
Laurel tavern or Laurel something sure
more hardware hardware that's what is
there I think I was there right yeah you
were okay and Brian at the end of the
meal they steal nice meal nice meal a
lot of friends a lot of laughs yeah
Brian says hey to me he says secretly
pay for this whole meal that's and it
was nice that you thought of everyone
else that we should that should be taken
care of okay well I do remember that any
kind that's not very I don't know if
it's positive because I'm is negative
being a dick no but it happened I was
there that did happen yeah
Brian was like offering what the people
who's trying to don't know because you
were poor yeah yo people we bear I've
never met it was because you were
bragging about all your money and I
thought maybe you should put your money
where your mouth is
and I paid for it because you bragging I
barely ate anything I did I paid for it
and didn't make a den but I just thought
it was nice no no you know huh B it was
so happy with yourself bro don't say all
right I know dude
we ordered a lot of food at a very nice
place good wine and good wine I don't
even drink yeah you suggested that I pay
for everyone right and I did okay okay
and the interesting thing about that is
okay it didn't make a dent right right
now right no it didn't make it didn't
make a dent
right but it bothered you it's so
obnoxious I was listeners rightly so
because you're bragging about the money
you make it's so obnoxious what because
it can all be taken away from you as you
know so show us know that on the way
general those people are not gonna be
there to catch oh dude
why do you think I'm building this cult
so that when the [ __ ] hits the fan you
got people to catch you so on the [ __ ]
hits the fan I can still [ __ ] and suck
you ain't mug at least most cult leaders
don't say it out loud and that's the
problem with cults dude I am reinventing
the idea of a cult and that's not bad
dude because you know what man a lot of
people think that they see reality for
what it is right right
take an umpire okay okay all right how
often are they making the right call
they mess up I mean they mess up a lot
but they're literally sitting in front
of what they think happened all right
okay okay no to do their job machines
can do their job can't they and a lot of
machines can do their job better but
we're humans and when we look at reality
we perceive what happens and it may be
right or it may be wrong but when you're
chill
with us and you're having a good time
and you're leaving and living a
hedonistic lifestyle none of that
matters dude because it's all about now
what what's the most what's the past
does it exist no it doesn't exist
because it happened ask you a question
it's about now the only thing that
matters is now do the thing that matters
is now preached the only thing that
matters is now pretty when that doesn't
matter anymore because you know what
matters now okay I see a question sure
how much what it costs for me to join
your cult you want to do a monthly thing
or you want to make so much sense in
your eyes once you pay that's an ass huh
okay okay oh man that is very powerful
let me just say Wow
once you pale he almost caught me once
you're for sure
that's why it's in the past holy the
only thing that matters is now he's
making just how much sense but I'm gonna
fight this [ __ ] like a car dealer anyway
congrats on you thanks so tour no less
[ __ ] the [ __ ] dude
I lost guest of the Europe by up percent
one percent the [ __ ] is that I didn't
post about [ __ ] I didn't push it I win
[ __ ] this Theo von Lucky's got race he's
a colleague please dude he's always got
two first names he's out he's out what's
your real last name [ __ ] out here Chris
don't be so babies I kind of let you
down man I decided that [ __ ] if I
pushed it oh dude I'll tell you what man
guest of the year 2018 right here now
it's over all right
totally display right man now is there
anything we can talk about that doesn't
[ __ ] revolve around you
I'd love to in your cult well let me
where does where does where does daddy
get his kicks from I got a guy might
have a better shoe clutch than me huh I
don't know you said you have a lot she
was not matter that did a quantity over
quality maybe well no but you you have a
lot you also you also like a lot of
different kinds yeah like just one I
like I like like you know adidas boots
and [ __ ] and like like easy
like I like Jordans are like airmax I
like some Reeboks but like that get to
your kids
I mean I've different people I have a
guy named Angelo that's that that that
guy you [ __ ] I have a shoe guy dude
and you know what I'm not sorry about
this [ __ ] man I'm tired of [ __ ]
people asking you to apologize dude I
have a shoe guy oh my god you have a
closet full of shoes your your that's
all about not I have a shoe guy dude and
that sometimes that your stock X it
doesn't [ __ ] matter I'll have a shoe
guy Brian yeah welcome mm you [ __ ] a
he realistic [ __ ] materialistic this
guy's weren't [ __ ] Sambas oh I'm
sorry is an indoor soccer game than a
breakdown or a street fight so I'm ready
a street fight dude cuz I sit down on my
punches now listen me yes sir did you
watch any of the Olympics yeah I saw
some of the curling bro it's that all
about hey stop stop curling terrible
sport I feel like the three of us could
do it it's a sport a sport or a game do
it game did you hey or is it a hobby is
this a [ __ ] Olympics why shuffle or
did you invite your friends over that's
what that [ __ ] is they're like this way
and then they just let it go ginger
let's see if you have to let some [ __ ]
go gingerly you're not in the Olympics
love you like Jamaica Jovi banana joke I
feel like if the three of us got
together and gave us a day and we had
someone teach us how to do it we could
do all right okay that goes beautiful oh
my G about moans you miss out on kiya
no I'll casually casually Dremel that's
her there
Chappell my sister Pam I'll see you at
the man Bryan back off bro sister pal
wow she looks like Natalie Portman
dude you know what man alien Guiana see
you're being sexist - yeah your soul
that's a human being she has a [ __ ]
and a sock and how did I say women run
yes no dude it could be guys oh my god
um look at her she is astonishing and
it's s yeah and the cool thing about her
last name is really easy frowns
right Bryce of Allah brides of gold
breeze anesthesia possibly gal ova i
watch shell rolling I was it
was in Canada for way too long I was in
Canada first she's married back off you
you know you know what that means game
she's gonna get [ __ ] divorced Chris
you get me a surefire way to [ __ ]
split up get married dude come on dude
that's a handsome guy um she's not
gorgeous
oh I think they're mad at us next door
really know their [ __ ] or they might
just be moving stuff yeah I think
they're moving in there who's [ __ ]
mad at you what would you add no and
we've had this idea for a while
all right listen listen hey look it's a
picture of Brian in his career so so
what's the deal what what is um what's
it is what another picture oh that's the
chick I thought I'm sorry I thought no I
thought that was a picture there I
thought it's picture you and your career
that's a slippery slope Chris we're
supposed to make this apologize and
that's why I give you guys certificates
you guys didn't bring [ __ ] what are you
growing on your face honestly you know
what I tell Bo beard no no it's a hobo
no it's not why wouldn't you shave just
your neck it's politically incorrect to
call them AHA Bo well I don't give a
[ __ ] cuz you look like a hobo
all the time though you would look like
a junkie no I know that no you know
whatever you know in my cult you don't
shave you just let it happen when was
the last time all [ __ ] aside your
skin saw the Sun 2015 is okay you look
like you've been working out then how
many hours do you sleep at night
twelve okay okay you're a mollusc
that's just relaxing you don't read
anything right oh that's [ __ ] what
if what was the last thing you read um
transcript of my podcast what what
exactly is your podcasts about oh dude
that's my favorite question it really is
all right well let's hear it bro you
know why cuz you don't deserve a [ __ ]
answer that's why no I'm in the club I
don't know I'm not saying you I'm just
saying when people ask me that you are
in the club and my podcast is about how
I feel about things okay and it's also
about what happened to me the past week
and you listen and you and it's not you
yeah dude and it's about entertainment
and it's fun and I and we break down the
rules of society and that's it
Chris why do you call your friends that
hang out with you what do you refer to
your friends when where it's where's
eating why do you go
hey sidekick guy in a movie who has five
lines no hold on you gotta bring this up
Jim go back to Chris's Instagram I was
laughing so [ __ ] hard have you seen
what he did oh yeah his opener was
talking [ __ ] to him bragging how he
bought this new outfit he's gonna show
Chris up so Chris no Chris yeah well I
the exact same outfit and showed up at
the club show this video
chintz so it's it's a [ __ ] up up up up
up up one more in the middle there all
right cool you just play so last night
was fun
some went down I'm gonna tell the story
here but all week last week my opener
was telling me about this new outfit he
bought I finally got a new outfit cuz he
never wears good clothes and he was
talking about how on Friday I'm when we
did the show we were gonna do the show
together and how he was gonna kill it
now is gonna be the star because he's
got this new outfit and finally people
are gonna be paying attention to him and
not me even though he's opening for me
and so he's got this new outfit from
g-star and he was so excited and he kept
showing us the picture and the group
text of the of the outfit and about how
cool it was and I was like we ain't he's
like you guys aren't [ __ ] when I put
this outfit on so I went the day before
the show and I bought the same outfit
and I wore it as well to [ __ ] his whole
night up now go to the next one last
night this is the outfit like it's a
[ __ ] it's a specific thing it's not
like just a black t-shirt and [ __ ] you
know so it's got the logo and then the
motocross knees which is looks like
you're trying too hard but you got to do
it you got to ruin your friends nights
your friends nights honestly [ __ ] I said
you ain't [ __ ] if you don't do that and
he's got the B he's like I got black
Jordans he didn't have the good ones I'm
gonna get you something heard the good
ones look at your shoes
the better version of the [ __ ]
Jordans that he has and where that pro
look at all you're doing his outfit
right okay next one
I didn't see this this is great oh look
he's got the same outfit on Oh precious
morally that is the craze Michael anoche
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh that's
so good that's so good ohh oh my god
you're so mean has no idea what the
saying is all right next one
I love Michael in our team Mike is funny
as [ __ ]
oh my god I was I think I should see
this I was in st. Louis I was at time
say house dress like daddy
oh god you son of a dude I was I was in
sailor skin we going yeah you I was
[ __ ] dying that [ __ ] good yo dude
so that's that now you're asking me what
happens if you go against the cult oh
there's an example Chris I'll be I
wasn't why was he trying to flex on you
yeah that's the thing dude don't flex
your humble dad yeah I'll flex on you
and beat you he goes on the road with
you or well like he's going on this I
bring him no for me okay I mean I have a
few guys I know she's fine yeah he's
really funny he's great I have a few
guys are open for me and he's he's one
of them I like using him you know I
using him are you gonna are you gonna
keep him down like like a lot of
headliners do to their feet you know no
I want I want them to thrive use him
look what you did for me and Chris
that's right I mean let I gave you guys
wings I got you up out of the nest it
was not comfortable at first but I got
you out of the nest and now you're
flying right yeah and now you're like no
no and I'm like don't do that you're
like are you a dragon I mean yeah you're
their site I'm just like and you're like
you know I'm saying wait that's my
that's the and I'm just like that's me
were you guys some he's kicking he's
kicking everything my Game of Thrones
you guys I wish you can see this he's
thank you
I know but people listening he's
reaching in the air the noise you make
is like this what's really jump your
next special that you never do should be
called oh I have never been more
insulted in my life
Chris are you like Brian when you're
exhausted oh my god busted from your
insult oh no Chris died ladies and
gentle please just wait till the
coffee-room drink to me coffee what if
he passed away right now yo you have the
beauty the most successful podcast of
all time probably if a [ __ ] comedian
died
oh my we and we would air it I'd want
you to dude we had one guy remember we
had that one guy who was on here I won't
say his name we didn't air remember he's
in the porn industry
yeah and he was like this the whole time
yeah oh Jesus Christ
yeah Allah I wish where to God I want my
on a series man I want my funeral to be
a celebration you know what I want my
funeral to be well I understand that and
that's cool and I like that idea you
don't know what my feet are little beat
I don't give a [ __ ] you know why dad
what am I gonna be like well but guys
know you're not gonna be thinking [ __ ]
you know what you're thinking nothing
well they slackline it I don't want any
dark they sell they they sell caskets
for like 50,000 Oscars they're
silk-lined
yeah that dude prop me up now put me
rock me up on a wall just like like
weekend at Bernie's vultures and
sunglasses on and put me high taxes so
when Bryan comes and pays respects he's
like not paying us I'm not paying oh you
finally get to you yeah and I'm still
higher you still win weekend at Bernie's
like those glasses like this I want them
like this you still win yeah no shirt
and I'm gonna get fat before I died too
like I need to get fast with you
disrespectful when I'm up there just
[ __ ] belly out with like you know
what jean shorts yeah
but Jeff shortens that's out the front
dude yes sure why not you know what you
can do it if you want yeah you know and
then and then but you know birds will
eat you
yeah it doesn't matter I'm damned Ian
door - the [ __ ] it matter if I'm dead
put me outside - I bet in burial oh yeah
sure okay well what'd they say cut you
open they split splay your head and they
let the vultures come and eat you but do
they split your head or split your head
because you said splice blight is split
in Tibetan mmm gotcha
yeah awesome dude Chris can we
acknowledge something it's kind of the
elephant in the room doing all something
that's to do with Brian so Brian's
waiting to hear about the big news about
his NBC show exactly doesn't care I'm
not waiting
I'm not it's like his entire life has
been hanging you know he says I don't
pay attention to it and then at night I
get these texts like what do you think
bro can you put a call in for Mia Leo
and I said I said I'm not gonna do the
work for right now right that's not true
so your show when you find out about why
it's Judah Friedlander on your belt mean
I'll try changing it don't try to meet
with a hat on okay cool hey Chris do you
have advice for Brian how to deal with
stuff like this well I don't want to go
back to the cult but it's all about now
thanks man there's nothing to do with
the present now I if the show gets
picked up then it doesn't matter because
about now if it doesn't get picked up in
the matter because it's about now okay
that there very easily not a new
philosophy you know but there's all the
philosophies are out there what we do is
we streamline it that sound like an
Instagram hot chick well no I'm just
saying it takes hard work you have an
inspirational quote for us today sure
what is it yeah the past is behind you
so live live now man that is really you
that is what I would do is so cliche no
no you know what I would do is I would
have a picture if I was gonna have a
picture a picture of an ice berg and you
just see the top of it about
dude that's socially Shane all right you
see the whole thing but bro that and you
see hard work dedication perseverance
yadda yadda and on the top part you see
success okay Chris that I created that
no that's so kind of like we've seen it
before I doubt it on oh my god so what
would you say to a young person who's
trying to make their way in the world
they tronic that they're looking at the
world what what is the advice you would
give them I would say I would say listen
to your parents but not too much because
they're not right about everything and
then oh and then they would and then I
go like this that's so general that
doesn't that's not a lovely hoping is it
be no because people need to find their
own way I would say look I can tell you
everything I know what I would say I
would say keep your eyes on the prize
and they say how long does it take and I
say it doesn't matter like if you're if
you're if you're focused on one thing
but you're thinking how long is it gonna
take you're keeping one eye focused on
the wrong thing by the way what you need
to do is keep both eyes focused on
what's it looked a terrible terrible
jugged of Davidoff i went to meet him
for drinks yeah and he's in New York I
mean in LA and he I see he's like ya
know on Monday and I see him sitting in
scopa and his back is he's sitting on a
bench kind of staring in a wall with his
notepad drinking wine and I come over
and I go why are you not sitting at the
bar and he goes because the guy over
there is on a date and he looked at the
girl and he looked in her eyes and he
said all we can be is ourselves I had to
leave up in life Wow he can't he can't
even say hitting me next to that [ __ ]
yeah I hear you and guys like you all
right Chris I'll get pissed hard before
Ukraine bands go past that cool what do
you mean do you stop yeah not go I'll
take over okay
Wow I'll talk about whatever don't let
him take the reins be well it'll piss
hard I don't have to piss right now he's
scared Brian Scott where you gonna dance
gotta pee take your phone with you bro
you got some high waters now you know
he's gonna do he's gonna go piss and
take pictures of it and toss it online
I was just puffing pissing I've seen him
do it before he deletes it real quick
I'll pass um amen so what's up man now
it's just now that it's just us just
killing it well yeah he fancies himself
you know like big comic now you know
what I mean we could both probably take
him right
no no both of us the three of us
couldn't take him the three of us would
lose and and I mean I mean if we're
really fighting yeah he would kill us in
the room and he'd kill us quickly it'd
be really weird like the only way is if
he attacked you and I you're useless no
no dude I'm not you're truly useless I'm
very honest Lee you know what I swear to
god I'm not trying to be a dick you are
as useful as the couch like if the couch
was in the room or Chris is in the room
well let me tell you something if I need
a help in fighting Brennan a life in
that location you would you're you're
basically a soft man no but I have a
counterpoint does a couch get hurt
what does a couch get you know what he
could do do you know D kill me and just
ignore you and you dude you'd be a
simpering Shh [ __ ] pile in the corner
not true dude hey hey dude I don't rate
for six dollars lie down and I do it I
want that's the thing hedonistic
lifestyle dude I don't give a [ __ ] what
you want me to do I'll sit how I want
and I'll do it anywhere I'll be in court
sit like this I don't get listen sit up
or I'm gonna I'm gonna come out here oh
[ __ ] man what you trying to kiss me no
that's your you're trying to kiss me oh
that's how you defend yourself I know I
just thought about the people only
listening and not seeing it is that you
that's your defense against a
male-on-male attack oh dude you just
alright let's see what else no no I
can't even you're you're going kneeling
you're trying to kiss me and your hands
are all soft oh wow that's how you
defend your salary's lotion have some
self-respect and defend yourself
[Music]
got your way God hey hey hey
you should see how he defends himself
watch this no I don't wanna watch me
come at him
tries to kiss at you it's not bad
see and that's really why are you out of
breath ro ran back you got a bum ticker
widen I ran back what'd you do [ __ ]
strength training he's been running you
smiling what are you doing wrestling
dude did you get high up in there man Oh
bye-bye man smoke crack oh no it's awful
man dude why you super vets Jen hey
what's this you roasted some opener on
the road didn't know your name your time
on your podcast I was laughing what did
I do
so you weren't oh oh you heard that dude
have us be know so were you what is it
you're on the road and then I'm open I
didn't know your name well okay so you
know I'm in North Battleford which is
like it's like an hour and a half away
from Saskatoon which is which is which
is up there Canada yeah it's up there
you're hurt nah you need to do these no
they pay me they went to a guide they're
like you want to go to casino so was a
car lot half cars it's an so anyway um
so so so the guy shows up and he was
like hey man and I was like ah hey he's
goes he says what's your name
and I was like Chris the guys opening
for me he's a comedian and the casino
booked them that's the casinos a lot of
times booked their own yeah yeah yeah I
said ah my name is Chris D'Elia and he
says how cool and I was like oh cool
and I was like whatever he didn't don't
know my name or maybe you know I have
pronounced it fine not a big deal not
everybody needs to know who I am
I'd like to think if you're a comedian
you you would just you know open him for
Christmas it's really if you're gonna
open up how big is this place it wasn't
big it was a casino in the middle of
nowhere you're right okay so so so I was
like so I was like are cool and he said
so the next question he said he's he
said what what's your how how about a
what what what music do you listen to
and I said I literally said what what
music do I listen to and he said yeah
and I and then he said like what do you
what do you what do you what do you do
and I said why don't I just kind of
chill out and hang out and depends you
know and I do but I listen to hip-hop
and and and he said oh so what what's
your what's your show like and I said I
mean I just get up there and kind of
tell jokes and he said oh you're a
comedian oh my god and I said yeah uh
right yeah and he said oh oh then I'm
gonna stay and watch you I thought you
were I thought you were a musician it
makes sense so if the way you look at me
short or-or-or you do magic and you are
all set to be fair you always walk
around with a guitar I do I always walk
around with a guitar and I do a lot I
have a heavy eye makeup well you like
what no I am but I was like so interest
but I was like and and you know I was
told to come and do him yes but he was
like my older yeah he was like 47 I mean
older than me but he was like younger
than but he was like but he was like do
you do you he is like I just got the gig
I didn't really ask I just said yes and
I was like oh it's all good and I was
like when today he's like I just got the
gig I didn't look you up or anything I
was like ah cool and he was like I was
like well what did you get the gig and
he was like two days ago he got time to
Google me did you say sir do you live
under a wrong I mean whatever I'm not
that big I understand but like he's a
comedian he's gonna open for me
yeah that's kind of yeah just how was
this comedy I actually didn't really
listen III have a feeling though every
time I checked in it was very like
Canada and local ship yeah you know but
uh you know yeah there are I'm listening
to comics sometimes can be like you get
to a point you can hear about 30 seconds
yeah and you understand yeah you get it
you get it it's really it's interesting
like you can you can tell just by their
confidence and their setup and just
[ __ ] hey what's up the music I mean
like you can hear that you you know
and I'll see you guys bring a comic you
have your own open yeah usually
otherwise I'll confirm him on issue like
dude I was in Canada before you even
said I was in Canada for a week I didn't
have an opener with me because I had to
shoot the good doctor and then run
around and do some gigs in which is too
expensive to fly amount [ __ ] and I was
just like in the middle of I was like
alone
yeah yeah that's usually why bring my
brother with me but you do yeah I bring
my brother and me almost everybody does
all the heat yeah and then I do if like
I'm in La Jolla or if it's somewhere
close I'll bring that hey soo straight
off oh he's [ __ ] crazy I love that
but I've been having fun because when I
go all around when I go to all these
freakin nights you know every city I'll
have their local comic with me yeah and
then some are monsters and then some of
them not so much yeah yeah and you can
see what some are brutal yeah somewhere
brutal and I'm like man I'll tell the
manager Mike you guys and it's a good
club Mike you guys have them open for
everyone yeah I'm like dang that's crazy
because huh do you know someone like
holy [ __ ] how are you not yeah there's
this the guys works like hey move dude
and then you go back a year later or two
years later the same guy you're like and
and they always say yeah I'm gonna get
that out to LA this summer and they
don't come and they take my number dude
sure it's gonna fit you're just gonna
you're not gonna make it do it and
that's fine if you don't want to but
they do you know what happened to me I
know I have fun though I like not
knowing that there's that variable where
even listen if they bomb it does suck
for the overall show but I know I'm
gonna do my thing
yeah but it's fun having that variable
cuz I listen the guy brought up me up in
North Battleford he brought me up tell
me your name he was like he was said but
I mean openers get my name wrong oh you
would you'd be shocked
you'd be like it's like Chris D'Elia
something like in Canada not this past
time last time
Chris deli and dude and he was
bombing in a theater but how do you
solve in a theater with my crowd they're
[ __ ] so jacked yeah and this guy says
Chris deli why did you love this out I
got a girl in st. Louis she's like
alright everyone eat your headliners
you've been waiting for it it's Brandon
Scott and I got the mic and go are you
[ __ ] yeah you got it
Brandon Schwab makes me I go crazy hate
that I hate it I had a guy the only time
I ever had a like a real issue as I came
in he was my feature and he he was on
his phone and he looked up and he goes
something like so like that and I was
like alright that's all good yeah and
then he got up and started doing stuff
like this is a full house
and he started reading oh geez I'm his
nobody's trying jokes out yeah and then
and then people go tell be funny or
something like that somebody said that
and he then he turned on the crowd you
gotta go and so I came back and I go
like this I go um how long does this be
this is probably six seven years ago and
I came back and you know me you can't
get me mad I know you're the nicest kind
of crowd yeah and I came out and I said
I go dude dude I went dude here you're
reading from your name yeah and you're
turning them against you when I get up
there you maybe maybe maybe arises on
the bright time cuz it's a gonna be a
packed weekend it was a place where I'd
do well I know it's gonna be packed
weekend so maybe don't do that to joking
around you know I'm laughter yeah and I
get it you're trying to say please don't
do that yes right I do it appropriate do
your good stuff so that you can set me
up and yeah yeah also do your good stuff
cuz this people here to see Brian maybe
they're gonna like exactly what he said
he goes like this he goes DB he goes he
goes now you'll be fine now you'll be
500 yeah and I went I went he goes now
now you're not I you'll be fine dude
they'll like they'll like you'll be fine
and I'd like that dismiss me and I and I
just went I go but I won't be fine I'm
just telling you man and I just smiled
like that yeah you did it again the next
night and that's okay and I said to that
and what
I get a different guy a club owner
sample please the club owner said to me
she goes he's he's always been that guy
who could have been something how about
I'm not you see what city I was in and
who it was yeah I get in the room and
I'm sitting I can tell the vibes a
little weird like they're not really
talking mean I'm listening I'm the
punter on the football team I'm the
weird ball out when I'm around a comic
so I come in I'm overly nice I'm talking
it when can I can feel there's like this
weird vibe yeah and they're sitting I go
what's up fellas and nothing in Disco so
I'm like to me fun when tonight man I
think you know two sold-out shows the
Wednesday night excite for this man and
then the manager comes in she's like you
know good to see you know great
everything's sold out like the crowds it
easy man you got good fans like yeah it
crazy and then homeboy goes must be nice
to have your own audience and sellout
shows and you've been doing it for oh I
don't know a month and he said that yeah
it's that true would you say I and I
went I want excuse me and he goes I'm
just saying man you know it's a grind
for a lot of saud hey loser
why not your pride just I went the ad
man the whole goal is to build an
audience right and sell tickets I said
it's crazy man I've done over 100 shows
man so things are going good he goes it
must be nice I'll say that must be nice
so much she's just crying yeah I don't
take me I see out there brother like I
just want no other job you ready do a
show man I can't wait til after this
podcast you tell me who that is yeah I
wanted to go before the show right dude
you wonder why you're not yeah I know
it's that why would you dude gave me a
lie picked you out like I'm trying to I
know I know I don't like I don't like a
lot of like sayings and stuff but I had
an acting teacher who was an older guy
and it had a very influential guy but he
said he's always say attitude monitors
your talent and it monitors your life
and he said he was 70 or something yeah
he goes I've seen so many people who
could have done so many things in their
attitude their negative attitude just
stopped them and that's a classic
example you see it all the time you
especially see it with comedian yes you
know because they you're literally your
attitude is your act you know right and
then you bring it off stage and then you
see these guys and you're like and
they're just like [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
that guy and it's like yeah that's a
pool around and also you know we joke
around like
the time like they game some cash and I
get to the waitress and this opener
whose tell me how hard it like how hard
times are on them right now so he gave
me like the wad of cash and now you're
here I'm [ __ ] rich I don't need it
joking yeah going [ __ ] right yeah like
in the yes I'm doing cuz you talk were
for everybody yeah but I was gonna give
to no matter what I'm making a joke so I
feel like ours and you're generous you
do that yeah all the time I never take
that when we cash I make I give it to
the staff so I give that in the guy goes
unbelievable I thought I was serious I'm
like dude what is your I got I gotta
find out who well I know this guy I
don't think so so wait what do you mean
yeah I think hash you get what it would
mean like from The Comedy Store from
merch or if they give me cash from VIPs
where I usually I give it to all
employees and gotcha gotcha yeah he goes
unbelievable I'm like oh my god am I
even my brother cuz I'm you know Jay
Jay's like that's a [ __ ] joke
the guy's like have a good night I'm
like Jesus well so you got you say you
guys like how to that's wish I would
know it would be is weird because but I
wasn't yelling with kindness of course
yeah you're not gonna you're too busy
funny you sloppy right sloppy and the
same set for a long but it's just in
front it's just weird man like I don't I
don't know man it wasn't there the next
night here's that was at my doing if he
is listeners that was am i doing here's
here's the other thing too is is uh
people like the more comedians that are
doing well the more comedians will do
well like like leg [ __ ] exactly like
what what is it they don't get all this
whole thing that guy I want what that
guy has and I didn't get it cuz you got
its famine thinking right so it's a
taking that you're taking the whole pie
the pie keeps growing again think of it
you're taking the pie and I don't get as
big a piece it makes you threatened by
first of all I think actually I think
it's even deeper than that I think when
you see somebody especially like you who
work so hard and and and does so much
and never stops and you know you're
undeniable I told you that a long time
ago I'd you know watching you become you
know be this successful is your own
doing we had a long talk about yesterday
and I've just seen how hard you work and
everything else but I think some people
what happens is when they see him or
they see somebody doing well it reminds
of what they're not doing of course it's
such a reminder of how they're not yeah
doing what they're supposed to do
because it's so much easier to
procrastinate we all have it in a suit
it is it's it's so easy to do it that
you don't even realize you're doing like
I mean like you like guys who are just
at the Comedy Store and don't go up and
just like don't do other clubs and [ __ ]
like that they're doing that too can I
talk to two guys who we all know and
they were there like at 30 and I said
and they're talented but I said I looked
at her and I go guys the old guy has a
couple things to say of Aaron is right
since I'm I'm 21 years older than you
what the [ __ ] are you doing because
you're both very funny but in three
months you're gonna be my age you gotta
wake up oh yeah
you gotta wake the [ __ ] up yeah you know
yeah like what are you doing you ask
yourself that what are you doing you're
like a bummer where I do have a you have
a is there a point where your head yeah
do you know what I'm saying yeah dude I
[ __ ] yes man I I don't understand why
people don't see this I don't get it I
don't understand what they want either
right like like I don't think they like
I have goals do me I have legit goals
that I know what I want specifically but
the thing I say like you know sometimes
I'll do faint questions at my shows and
someone go what's the most surprising
thing about D'Elia or Hugh or rogue you
know Diaz or Theo or so on right and not
and you know people see Chris you know
you're you're silly and all that I'm
like you know you realize Chris works
harder than anyone I know
he's at the Comedy Store every single
night never never does not they never do
it like you're doing it you do comedy
and you do it right
you do it seven days a week don't you
yeah you do yeah unless I because you're
autistic I mean I know the respect no I
know yeah I I do I tell you like I don't
if I do I have two shows tonight I had
like I don't and I just got back from
Canada and I and when I'm in Canada
doing these shows I'm exhausted I'm
thinking I gotta take a week off and
then Monday rolls around and then I call
in my [ __ ] spots yeah it's just I'm
not I'm not because I know if I don't do
that on Tuesday night I'm just gonna be
like this right well no what about what
am I gonna watch what am I gonna watch a
[ __ ] show on TV right I'm gonna go
out I wanna do on set and that see
that's another thing dude that's how I
get material is like I'll go I'll keep
going I'll keep going I'll do them
insane material I get so [ __ ] bored
of it and then I just start talking
about something else that's right you
know cuz I'm - I'm - skit I get I'm not
gonna sit down and write you have a
you are a bit on the spectrum like in a
good but I mean I know you're not target
well maybe it's obsessive workaholic
yeah he can he you have it's an
interesting thing with you like you've
always been that way like your brother
told me that the only thing you were
interested in your the only thing is
being funny I tell you I'll tell you man
that's the [ __ ] goddamn truth man
yeah that's all I ever wanted man that's
just is he also wear this [ __ ] thing
people laugh yeah and ever since he he
said since they want the fossa day one
but aren't you like that the half course
yeah I'm glad that that's all we do yeah
all we don't give a [ __ ] though we do it
on as text and that way I don't like and
even when you start talking about
serious [ __ ] yeah like you like how
often when we talk the three of us or
whatever or we talked on the phone the
other day you get serious for three
minutes and then let's back then it's
because you're a failure to each other
you know don't say that nice too serious
yeah also everyone else like talked you
can't really joke like that
so seriously not be a cry but you know
what I think it is dude a [ __ ]
wavelength man that people you're either
on or you're not it's a frequency that's
a hundred percent no you see these you
see these you see these Instagram people
trying to do funny videos and they're
just seeing what oh this is what it's
like to be a funny person you're not a
funny person you're you're in your
[ __ ] kitchen that's all you are and
you're like let's make a video no it has
to [ __ ] speak to you it doesn't speak
to you dude alright mean you're someone
all right that's what you are you put on
a shirt you put pants on that's what you
do you know [ __ ] all right you don't hit
your father frequency dude man you sound
like an angry stop that's just alone if
you don't the frequency man and I don't
do that a lot you know I don't that's
what if your hey have you ever seen that
like meathead who goes on those rants
about he's great
oh that sounded like greatest have you
seen that yes the guy wears the bandanna
or
he's a guy so I saw people wait in line
and they're waiting for an iBook I
thought myself you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
ain't gonna throw the [ __ ] say but
he's like read just to get you don't
talk about classic he's so agro he's
amazing but yet some kind of instant
what I gonna find let's do some coronal
France Quran events with Brian the King
camera all right the first one is in
South Africa ally you know Kruger
National Park yeah we're all the lines
and wildebeest and all that stuff rat
some lions found a poacher who was
trying to kill them ended up killing the
poacher and eating him and then the only
thing left was his hey why did they
leave your head or no Harley and
sometimes your feet so I don't know
heads heart hey but also how many how
many times the people kill Alliance and
one for the good guys am i right yeah
one for the yeah yeah
so out of how many lines I mean lines
kill people a year it's kind of come on
then what yeah less less lines kill
people that people can lines end or
probably right
well that says in January 2017 three
male lines were found poisoning in
Limpopo with their Paul's and heads cut
off on T so that could have been another
lion that could have been has been on
the rise oh that sucks
alright yeah look here's the thing
here's the thing if I had to kill my own
[ __ ] food and be vegetarian it's too
hard yeah that's fair you know you know
I mean much work it's like yeah you're
not a hunter this is too hard
I'll just eat all the plants you know
Brian I remember and I date Brian I did
a show with Bert Kreischer is cooking
this is burnt soms but I love Burke
right the [ __ ] is my favorite on earth
shame we had to kill crabs I couldn't do
it right do it
Brian sociopath I know I killed I
literally could not do it I was like
and I'm not saying people shouldn't do
it no because I eat crab yeah I'm not
saying people shouldn't do it you shoot
your food eat it
I'll just plants plants don't run I grab
them and eat them
yeah with Chris on this all day I'll
just be careful there that's why you I
would go hunt and you would stay behind
and you would mash with no dude I'll
tell you what I would do you know I will
be doing mash then I would go raw water
from the well no and you have you would
go out you would go unpaired how about
this you present me with it what about
this yeah big there'd be a big welcoming
back party you'd have a dress on go hide
a nano that's actually not what will be
happening you know will be happening
while you're out hunting I would be up
in your girl's guts oh wow about that Oh
home by leaving it in Oh leaving my guy
and guess what and making me raise your
raise my kid clothing-wise your look
like oh alright well your call
that's you in four years okay yeah okay
anyway I'm your dad Oh more uh you are
so awful here you know it you're a
ghastly human being leaving you know
what I am bro what sneaky huh that's
what everybody needs to know Chris
sneaky delusion so Trump's what Trump
does I know what Trump does well it's
like what he's what his people have said
he does well Trump gets off on betting
his friends oh I know I know yeah but
yeah this guy's acting like he's the
[ __ ] know who didn't tell people this no
but he'll did I tell you what Trump does
he [ __ ] ran for president uh-huh but
do you know how he does it
like he's breaking dude what he would do
you're gonna tell me about when he was
on the phone yeah something yeah he gets
his he gets
did the wife on speakerphone says hold
on he's coming in disquieting is he gets
you to start talking about the court
your side pieces or your girls that you
fool around with and and then she's like
that son of a [ __ ] and he's like come
on we'll talk about it and then he has
sex with us you understand that's such a
you've said that that kind of guys in it
I think isn't that book you [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass mother [ __ ] moons the worst
kind of guy a lot of people have said he
does that
can ya tell a book and then he [ __ ]
your girl
imagine me they're never offered you Wow
what a terrible pain oh isn't you know
what you know what every time every time
I see if I like that every time I hear
about some [ __ ] like that I think about
like ah man he was he's such a dork I
don't know just a tool just a door plea
door in polos in those short shorts and
them door [ __ ] gesso [ __ ]
runaround go [ __ ] man it's so here's the
thing it's supposed to be hard to get
laid
you're not taking back doors sneaky ways
yeah you do the straight and narrow and
it's [ __ ] hard yep it's like hunting
exactly you're not [ __ ] you should
pop up you you don't [ __ ] he's the
vegetarian vegetarian he's a [ __ ]
well that if he's doing that he's a
piece of mark ass [ __ ]
I agree I didn't know that yeah what
else catch in this is a quick one so I
guess his administration is proposing a
new system instead of food stamps
they'll give you boxes prepackaged boxes
kind of like blue apron style with food
yeah but it'll be like hand foods like
shitty food not fresh foods what
everyone likes and [ __ ] though that's
not I think the freedom to go out and do
the [ __ ] man so yeah that's the thing
they're taking away some of their
dignity even though it sucks to be poor
and have to do tests you can actually
pick whatever you're right right come on
this [ __ ] they're like it's a candle
okey so that was proposed yesterday I'll
check this out I'm [ __ ] funny ah man
alright alright it's take it easy though
couple who quit jobs and soul belongs to
sail around the world lose everything is
boat capsized basically they say for two
years and they quit their jobs and it's
sunk in it hug and ginger yeah they say
their dog that sucks
wow wow it would be great if they've
boats sank but they saw that dog out in
the water at least we get a dog that is
such a bummer also I would never but
also don't do that yeah also don't do
that yeah it's true don't do that but
also what if that's your passion though
and that's what you want to do maybe
have some savings yeah I guess yeah he's
also after you sail around the world you
come back to
now right right right God man I think
they're not like experts either though
they just wanted to do it so he says I
sold everything I had to do this but I
also lost everything about of 20 minutes
yeah that's amazing
he's only 26 yeah that figures out
you'll figure it out so bad man about
sailing did they were they're not
experts it wasn't was it a sailboat no
sailboat yeah what yep and they don't
know sailing they don't know how well
that's Lord sailing is like not easy no
no it's not sailing is and does
you know Sam Sheridan who just crossed
the Pacific and the Atlantic much times
my buddy said you can get caught in
storms that last 72 hours
use your friend Sam no [ __ ] huh you tell
no [ __ ] I mean that you must be in the
middle of the ocean with it with a storm
like I hurricane and you're you're
bouncing around like a cork will you
hurt terrified waves a big wave no you
know what I would do no first of all no
there's nothing nothing you know why we
don't know what the [ __ ] in there
right know what miles deep it's you know
what's in there out of a base outer
space that's out or [ __ ] let me tell
you something under juries yeah true but
it dumps yeah so if the [ __ ] yeah but
obviously I'm making up but that was
good all right so look look look you're
out here and you see this [ __ ] Oh oh my
god a storm like perfect storm alack
wave what it's not it's not blue it's
not the absence of light and it [ __ ]
absence is like crushing down on you and
you don't even see it in front of you
you see it over you it's a building for
it it's behind you before it's a bill
check this out bro we got some waves
like now check this out though check
this out dude you know what I'm doing if
I see that I have all my faculties with
me I'm pissing myself on purpose to be
dramatic and whenever I got my hand I
purposely go oh and I drop it cuz I'm
gonna pretend I'm in a movie and I want
to be dramatic but
that's how you want a dog that's all
let's watch as the leader on what is
this is that you my welcomes are going
down not okay watch it now there's go
that's why them let's go this way and
then uh uh cuz you call every way that
that right there forget no you're
surfing here we go that's a mountain
this room is not Everest is so going
down
[Music]
they put down the camera do the yeah but
these are super super tall boats so the
fact that the waves of that higher
enormous this is me on a family vacation
better ones
Jesus Christ what the see is terrifying
miss it terribly sad Arab it came off
are what I'm speaking French bro sorry
man I'm did you just gotta go there are
those guys who say these are looted
tsunamis that's crazy look at masters if
you fall want to do it game over they
want to do it so bad that's the thing
look at this these are the crab boats
right yes si de la Mer
I don't know i speaking french bro
because look at the seams i know because
we have french spans we don't we to hold
and now we do though we don't this isn't
available in france that you want okay
really get it yeah one youtuber what
well you to know no whiners have only
five family but you'll get a different
money so why why I made that up news
have only a little funny I found that
when I brought those videos what else
you got
how about this one this giant boar in
Hong Kong why going through a contrast
bit without strong that Boris oh hello
you knew you mean bebop and rocksteady
from Turtles
that's the Ninja Turtle yeah that's the
tiny clip but holy [ __ ]
nothing GaN sometimes we would only take
four seconds of that we got it that's a
badass animal though I mean you got to
shoot that oh yeah you gotta ride him no
y'all ride him yeah you got to ride him
and you ever seen the board I killed the
the just the dude cuz they do the
walking
no that is such a badass animal what
they do with it I just kept going
how about [ __ ] you and dub it pigzilla
you look creative Hong Kong that's bebop
and rocksteady you [ __ ] pretty big
people and Rocksteady you know what I
realize do it if you go like this it's
like you're sucking a dick hurry up
quick Mme one monkey college on Jones's
manager
he said that if the USADA is respectable
with all the investigations they're
doing John Jones should be able to fight
within this year like three times like
they'll have enough information to you
know what do you call it I hope they're
right I hope he fell he says he still
would but when he says that if they're
respectable that doesn't he's saying
that they have all the facts as a
process of yes so they there that's how
strongly feel about this case with all
the facts that they have so well yeah
but he's also his age my age is also
some rock he's full of [ __ ] should be
out what he should be out if you fell
twice right well this well this would be
his third offense but the thing is is
that it's kind of it's a tough one
because there is evidence that he didn't
personally take it one state yeah oh no
you're wrong it he's into some [ __ ] but
they think it could be laced from the
cocaine eum's doing so oh [ __ ] actually
steroids and he actually did in Nowitzki
actually admits he took it unknowingly
so that's gonna help you yeah but even
unknown Lee if it's the second time you
should I can't imagine only be out for
like a year or season out for a while
now sure it's retro accidental too so he
married even find out you see 200 yeah
his last fight was gets well the D
season we knocked them out damn that is
a long time ago yeah how long does that
they should be cage matches where you
just do arguments about a courtroom ah
god damn it no can't be daddy when he
heard of the ocean s space oh it's outer
space under speak of that that wasn't
that long ago then join 2017 yeah it
wasn't that long ago wow I remember it
happened in like as you want remember
exactly I'm thinking of the first one he
doesn't do what he wants no I'm saying
oh not even that
well if he's aren't [ __ ] whatever
yeah it's get you man I don't know I
hope I hope he's back to and they'd 18
they could use them it's trippy you know
I don't give a [ __ ] just get them back
in yeah I kind of do it's just getting
worse life is it's entertaining I just
don't survive everyone sighs [ __ ] who
cares he's dumb enough to get caught
just let him do it
right what else you got kids in Utah and
elementary school in Utah they can't say
no on Valentine's
for the dance that's like sixth grade so
this school enacted a policy where they
can't say no to people that are asking
them to dance so it's kind of cool
though because if you know you can't
miss those fat you have to get bullied
or really in take some shots like that
it's kind of cool though
you remember those sixth grade dance or
just pinning its wall terrified with
your buddies like yeah you get all
dressed up
you play the music if I was on that
school and I couldn't say no I just like
fine that's so true yes it's kind of
good-natured it might be like you can't
tell now try we're getting but it's also
that the rest you know the inverted kids
are you know but the kids were you're
not gonna get in trouble at that school
that's always tough to get girls to
dance man and I want to predominantly
black school so that that dance floor
was a pop yeah was a pop yes and that's
[ __ ] never must be why I had so much
rhythm to be honest correct correct and
his that's why I DS why'd you hate white
it no did I did uh not a time but I was
forced to yeah what else yet chin I got
one more how about the levar ball thing
where he said that Lanza won't resent
the ladies are the same person in
disguise [ __ ] they [ __ ] dress like
they are anyway we're saying though chin
Lavar ball the dad said that Lanza the
guy that's in the Lakers he won't resign
with the Lakers unless the two brothers
get silently yeah he's just easily say
delusional but they all go Lakers don't
give a [ __ ] no they're not a Lakers
cause go gives a [ __ ] that's not the
YMCA the older one who's draft number
two and the the draft is actually legit
the other two aren't gonna make to them
being the little ones I kindly I think
you might be okay but they're not [ __ ]
the other one not [ __ ] the ice 14 you
but the Lakers don't work like that's
like what okay get the [ __ ] out of here
we don't care yeah we have enough
capital we could get LeBron James you
ever heard of them yeah Kwame Leonard
you ever heard of them who isn't like
Sean James Sanjay Hasan James who so so
the the one in the middle is a 14 year
old who was the car left ones the baller
oh he seems really legit if you don't
have so much pressure from his dad he
probably when Ricky of the year
really he's dad's [ __ ] it up for him
to be
his dad's done a great job get him there
was dad just won't get out of the way
like the Lakers and the rest Lee can't
stand the father they've actually banned
him from the post interview since days
Jesus just yeah just stop like he's
their man let he did it he's putting so
much pressure on his kid this kid did
just come out with a new rap yeah I
heard about that
stop stop play basketball do that did
which one which one came out with the
one who laid one on the Lakers damn it
you listen well so he's on the Lakers
Annie's rapping interesting what about
the so so the the middle one is not
gonna he's just not gonna make it man
chances both no anyone else make it's
not good I'm gonna try for Lakers it
should broke they have open parking yeah
they're like like that movie invincible
like be that guy that it chin uh well
this is Olympics I don't know if you
care about this one yeah a little girl
Chloe Kim ah she's apparently destroying
competition she wanna go build a
halfpipe hap she's snowboard young too
yeah double American girl right yeah yes
she's crushing it how old is she 17 so
ins but she's destroying there's like no
competition first do you pay any
attention to the Olympics yeah look I
told you I looked at curling and [ __ ]
well you just watch curling like I give
a [ __ ] dude we're gonna softer those
broker you get the [ __ ] out of there
they're terrible Stan Stan you have the
worst you have the worst outfit on for
real no but for real
you don't mustard [ __ ] pants and and
you'll that be tailored to an your
myscholar block you and they're all
worst and they're the worst socks so
they're not honestly they're beautiful
do terrible I look good bro no you don't
he doesn't get it right he has no idea
no honestly man you have bad fashion
sense okay I'm a fashion block look at
these brown shoes ready
no that's myself a classic so tight
because I'm using my feet [ __ ] those man
that [ __ ] stupid shake of those oh
[ __ ] a war that [ __ ] ain't a great huh
what's with these beds you should
[ __ ] idiot it's a chair listen Chris
I want to say [ __ ] you wrap this [ __ ] up
man you're not invited on the podcast
anymore well we'll see if he gets here
all right I appreciate this stuff this
is just for guests a year and you're not
honey [ __ ] us all right
but I appreciate it man I'm an elder I'm
wearing this with pride you're my first
friends that are elders all right well I
take that serious man yeah
you know we're gonna frame these and put
these up in here cool okay I'll okay
yeah hey Brian we're almost done with
the show can you wait sorry you'd be a
professional company offers you have so
much disrespect for your friend here he
brings you this in our Texan apologize
trying to end this listen don't join
Chris Chris is torn Josie Marcus follow
the leader if you would like you you go
see him he's the bus and truck version
of me at the end of the day and that's
fine bus and fuzz yeah yeah that's
saying is like oldest kid by the way you
should see the reference to gave me
yesterday man God can you get younger
nope is there any way I'll tell you what
man nope I'm wrong listen to my podcast
bro huh come congratulations about what
happened to Chris that day no dude it's
about pancreas stop well what do you
guys talk about that's new isn't [ __ ] I
do that too you don't know anything
about the news
[ __ ] [ __ ] give us some
perspective on they King they can get
your tickets at wazooloo.com or at Bryan
Callen no you can't get my tickets there
what if you're a fan of if you're a fan
of mine don't go to Brian [ __ ] what I'm
asking Wow
you can't say powerful man do not go
Chris Oh with or go with signs that say
we love Chris no let me come see me this
weekend actually this Wednesday at the
Tempe improv I'll tell you what they'll
be tomorrow's a Friday Saturday yep
tomorrow and Thursday Friday Saturday at
stand-up live and fit I'll tell you what
if you're from fan of mine and you're in
the Phoenix area don't go Chris that's
not nice you can't you can't
Valentine's Day [ __ ] do you know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna jerk off knocking
until Marshalls I'll tell you what you
know what bright you know what Brian's
gonna do dude there's what I'm I asked
about Brian hey Brian how many tickets
are left in for your Phoenix shows
40,000 hey could we get a promo code
there's a 40,000 tickets you don't need
one go on
brew Chris dude hey crew bug retic no go
see you next week I'm in La Jolla Comedy
Store Friday night Saturday night only
then after that
I'm in Florida cut around the same time
as you I'm in Florida at the end of
March
Tampa Palm Beach Orlando boom boom boom
your teeth now for myself
Bryant count tik calm go see Chris
D'Elia daddy in the house this is the
fine kid with daddy
we're out